Traduttore: Elisa Vitale
Revisore: Michele Gianella
(Applausi)
Buonasera a tutti.
Devo confidarvi una cosa prima d'iniziare:
probabilmente, ma non diciamolo
agli organizzatori
che probabilmente non ci ascoltano,
se avessi saputo che voi
sareste stati così tanti,
se avessi saputo che in streaming
ci stanno vedendo in più di mille persone
e se avessi saputo che sarei dovuta
entrare come dodicesima speaker,
probabilmente
non avrei accettato l'invito.
Ma ovviamente sto scherzando
perché voi siete fantastici
e sono veramente orgogliosa
di poter partecipare a questo TEDx,
quindi grazie davvero per l'invito.
(Applausi)
A proposito di futuro,
io qualche giorno fa ho voluto...
ho provato a fare un gioco
che in realtà non si è dimostrato
poi neanche così divertente.
Ho digitato sulla barra di ricerca Google
il binomio Italia Futuro.
I link, le pagine, gli articoli
a cui sono stata rimandata
hanno suscitato in me,
ma credo in chiunque abbia
un minimo di sensibilità,
un'espressione come questa.
Ho provato sgomento,
ho fatto un urlo silenzioso, soffocato,
ma comunque molto potente,
come quello passato alla Storia
e dipinto dal grande artista Munch.
Ho provato sgomento
di fronte a una quasi inscalfibile,
a una cruda, quasi unica
possibile lettura di un paese,
il nostro, completamente allo sbando,
smarrito e senza possibilità di riscatto.
Un paese fermo, stagnante,
in continua recessione.
Considerate che dal 2008 ad oggi,
ci sono 2 milioni
di posti di lavoro in meno.
Meno di un cittadino su due è occupato.
E oggi sono tanti, troppi
quei giovani inattivi
che non studiano
e non cercano lavoro,
i cosiddetti NEET,
che vengono etichettati
con un bollino in fronte,
proprio come si fa
con un prodotto qualunque
su un nastro trasportatore.
Le aziende chiudono,
i negozi tirano giù le saracinesche,
e quelle imprese che tentano di tutto
pur di non dichiarare fallimento,
delocalizzano.
E in questo modo lasciano per la strada,
lasciano nello smarrimento più totale,
tutti quegli uomini e tutte quelle donne
che di fatto non erano
solo operai o dipendenti,
ma erano anima stessa dell'impresa
che hanno contribuito a far crescere,
diventando parte di storia
dell'impresa stessa.
I consumi calano, la povertà cresce,
aumentano le diseguaglianze
economiche e sociali
e abbiamo un welfare
completamente inesistente.
Siamo il paese dell'incertezza,
siamo il paese dell'austerità.
Ma un dato che mi ha colpito
più di ogni altro,
è che siamo il paese
più infelice del mondo.
Non so se lo sapete...
(Applausi)
Ma l'80% - siamo il popolo
meno contento del mondo.
L'80% di noi
si ritiene insoddisfatto.
E mettiamo caso
che in questa sala siamo 100,
solo nove di noi ritengono
di poter trovare un posto
all'interno della società.
Un esempio di rassegnazione,
di morte dell'ambizione,
di totale incapacità di sognare.
È per questo che i giovani oggi...
i giovani come me oggi scappano.
E quelli che restano
si aggrappano ai grandi,
ma senza prospettive,
senza aspettative,
senza la voglia di potersi costruire
un futuro da soli.
Siamo quelli della generazione perduta,
come quella raccontata da Hemingway
quando si riferiva a tutti quei ragazzi
che hanno vissuto la propria giovinezza
nel bel mezzo della Prima Guerra Mondiale.
Io credo che oggi
non sia poi così diverso.
i ragazzi della mia età, i miei coetanei,
stanno vivendo la propria giovinezza
nel bel mezzo di un altro conflitto,
magari meno chiassoso,
ma comunque spaventoso,
che è quello del nichilismo.
Dopo essermi ripresa
da una paralisi facciale
per aver imitato l'urlo di Munch,
mi sono posta però queste 3 domande.
Ma veramente l'Italia è solo questo?
Ma veramente noi italiani
e il nostro paese,
ma soprattutto i nostri figli
e i nostri nipoti
non hanno e non avranno
un futuro?
Ma soprattutto,
il futuro a chi appartiene?
Io non sono una veggente,
non sono una cartomante,
non sono una maga
con poteri soprannaturali,
ma sono una ragazza di 25 anni
che si sta costruendo il futuro
con le proprie mani in questo paese
e che passa gran parte del suo tempo
su un trattore, e con le mani
in mezzo alla terra.
(Applausi)
E da scorpione ascendente ariete
quale sono,
ci sono in me, vivono in me
delle grandi convinzioni
di cui difficilmente
riuscirete a privarmi.
La prima:
io sono sicura che dovremmo guardare
all'Italia con occhi diversi.
Dovremmo essere in grado
di cambiare sguardo sul nostro paese.
di allontanarci da quella foschia
che accompagna la considerazione
che noi italiani abbiamo di noi stessi
e del nostro paese.
E allora scopriremmo
un paese che ce la fa.
Un paese che punta sui suoi talenti,
un paese che punta sui suoi territori,
sulle sue comunità,
sulle sue tradizioni,
sulle sue conoscenze.
Scopriremo un paese che non è vero
essere senza futuro,
a patto però che riparta da ciò
che nel mondo ci rende eccellenza:
la bellezza, il genio e la creatività.
E la qualità, che nel mondo
è sinonimo di Italia,
e che trova il più alto riconoscimento,
la più alta espressione e forza,
nel nostro "Made in Italy".
Se sapessimo guardare all'Italia
con occhi diversi,
ci accorgeremmo di Giulia.
Giulia ha la stessa età anagrafica di chi
oggi viene considerato "cervello in fuga".
Oggi Giulia invece è rimasta.
E dopo una laurea magistrale
in architettura,
ha deciso di aiutare la propria famiglia
a portare avanti
un progetto di agricoltura sociale.
Oggi Giulia in Veneto accoglie
bambini disabili,
ragazzi e genitori in difficoltà,
all'interno della propria azienda.
Alcuni di questi bambini
hanno iniziato a parlare,
gli adolescenti che erano
considerati ormai persi
hanno ritrovato la fiducia in se stessi,
la motivazione alla vita e al lavoro.
Alcune famiglie sono rinate.
Oggi, Giulia, che è rimasta in Italia,
in Veneto aiuta un sacco di persone
a ritrovare la fiducia in se stesse,
crea posti di lavoro,
genera occupazione e ricchezza.
Se sapessimo guardare all'Italia
con occhi diversi,
ci accorgeremmo di Luigi.
Luigi è nato e cresciuto in Calabria,
quella Calabria che troppi
guardano da lontano
per paura di sporcarsi.
Luigi invece è orgoglioso
di essere calabrese
e ad Oriolo Calabro produce un amaro
con i suoi ulivi
di cui lui stesso si prende cura,
e con una ricetta antica della nonna,
rimasta nascosta e chiusa in un libro
per tanto, troppo tempo.
Oggi Luigi lavora con i migliori
chef stellati internazionali.
Oggi Luigi esporta il suo prodotto
in tutto il mondo,
e con esso l'immagine
di una Calabria
che sa produrre e creare occupazione.
Ma soprattutto,
oggi Luigi ha reso la sua nonna
la donna più orgogliosa del mondo.
Se sapessimo guardare all'Italia
con occhi diversi,
ci accorgeremmo di Francesco
e i suoi amici,
tutti provenienti da mondi diversi,
che un giorno hanno deciso
di investire e rischiare.
Oggi Francesco e i suoi amici producono
una birra artigianale a chilometro zero.
Hanno trasformato il loro sogno
in un'attività economica e remunerativa,
un'attività che mette in connessione
la voglia e la grinta
di un gruppo di ragazzi
che ha deciso di costruirsi
il proprio futuro
con la storia e l'identità storica
del territorio senese.
Oggi Francesco e i suoi amici
coltivano l'orzo nelle colline toscane.
hanno aperto un birrificio,
in una birreria dove lavorano
dieci dipendenti, tutti under 35.
Giulia, Luigi, Francesco e i suoi amici,
sono solo una piccola rappresentanza
di quel futuro possibile
che oggi tanti ragazzi come loro
e tanti ragazzi come me
si stanno costruendo nel nostro paese,
che non vogliamo abbandonare.
Oggi Giulia, Luigi, Francesco
e i suoi amici
rappresentano i giovani di Coldiretti,
quei giovani che stanno investendo
in un nuovo modello di sviluppo,
che ci racconta di un'Italia
che sa primeggiare nel mondo,
di un'Italia che primeggia
per efficienza ambientale,
per meno CO2 e meno rifiuti
prodotti dalle imprese,
di un'Italia che accoglie più turisti
statunitensi, canadesi, australiani,
brasiliani di ogni altro.
Di un paese che vanta
più di 120 prodotti agroalimentari
unici al mondo per la loro qualità.
Giulia, Luigi, Francesco e i suoi amici
stanno costruendo
il proprio futuro sulla terra,
sulla pietra più solida, concreta
e così alta da poter guardare lontano,
che è la terra.
E qui risiede la mia seconda convinzione:
che nei nostri territori inimitabili,
nel nostro cibo identitario,
sicuro e democratico,
che nel rispetto delle comunità,
nella dignità delle persone
e nel rispetto dell'ambiente e del lavoro,
risiede quella strada
che noi tutti stiamo cercando
per poter dire a noi stessi,
ai nostri figli e ai nostri nipoti
che l'Italia ha un futuro.
Giulia, Luigi, Francesco e i suoi amici
ci insegnano che non dobbiamo
bendarci gli occhi,
aspettando che qualcuno faccia di noi
quello che meglio crede.
Ci insegnano che non bisogna
cercare modelli altrove,
altri modelli alternativi possibili
da poter imitare.
Ci insegnano che con determinazione,
passione, grinta, audacia, pazienza
e un pizzico di follia
ognuno di noi si può costruire un futuro
in questa meravigliosa Italia.
Ci insegnano che ognuno di noi
deve essere responsabile di se stesso,
ma con sempre uno sguardo
rivolto agli altri,
affinché ciò che di bene faccio per me,
di buono faccia per il mio paese.
Ma soprattutto ci insegnano
la mia terza convinzione,
che il futuro appartiene a coloro che
credono nella bellezza dei propri sogni.
La nostra Italia è piena
di sogni e di sognatori,
e questi sognatori
ci dimostrano ogni giorno
come questi sogni
possano diventare realtà.
Coldiretti li scopre, li racconta
e li sostiene da anni,
e continuerà a farlo.
Con un breve video,
ve li voglio presentare,
affinché ognuno di noi in questa sala
[possa decidere] se non possa credere,
ma almeno sperare come me,
che l'Italia, se investe su ciò che di
buono la nostra terra ha da offrire,
e su una nuova economia
fatta di persone, di socialità,
di solidarietà, di cultura
e di conoscenza,
ha un futuro, ed è più roseo
di quello che possiamo immaginare.
Grazie a tutti e buona visione.
(Applausi)
(Inizia il video)
4957 km in 11 giorni
dal nord al sud dell'Italia
per raccontarvi i migliori talenti
dell'agricoltura italiana.
Finalisti Oscar Green 2014
21 finalisti nazionali
tra 1152 concorrenti,
7 categorie per vincitori
Le eccellenze del Made in Italy
Le avanguardie dell'innovazione
La terra ha un futuro
A novembre
Seguici su
www.oscargreen.it